all right let's turn to sunday's vmas we
know it's gonna be different but it's
also gonna be pretty epic
[Music]
blue hair blue nails oh lady gaga is
ready to conquer the vma stage like a
champ
she even prepped for sunday with this
hardcore ice bath do i partner ariana
grande
she's amping up the glam while staying
safe
love ariana love lady gaga i saw the
video they killed it so i know the
performance is going to be
nuts kiki palmer is set to shine as the
knights emcee
i really get to utterly be myself new
talk show host drew barrymore kelly
clarkson and jayden smith are among
those helping to present along with
megan fox's new man machine gun kelly
and model bella hadid
her ex the weeknd is performing so are
fellow nominees miley cyrus
and bts
how is this show going to be pulled off
in the midst of a pandemic we're getting
as creative as we can
and trying to make sure that we can
incorporate our awesome audience but
within a way that's safe for everyone so
expect a cool surprise there
first big change no indoor performances
final touches were being made on outdoor
stages across new york's five boroughs
and maluma was just seen rehearsing in
brooklyn
well the preparation of the show was
very very interesting i could say the
show will be live with recorded elements
and fans will safely take part
one two three some watched maluma set
from their own cars
we're figuring out all different ways
that we can keep the excitement and the
surprises going
on
another change a few insta-famous first
responders will be honored from
jefferson university hospital swab squad
to jason campbell aka
tick tock dots
[Music]
there are also two new categories best
quarantine performance and best music
video from home
john legend's up for both for his duet
and his fan sourced video